After months of speculation, and a recent leak
that sent fans into a frenzy, the "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" trailer is finally here.
From what we've seen so far, the film wastes
little time in addressing Peter Parker's
less-than-ideal situation following the events of
"Spider-Man: Far From Home," in which everyone's
favorite superhero was framed for the death of
Mysterio and outed to the world as Spider-Man.
Lost and seeking answers, Tom Holland's
Peter Parker turns to Doctor Strange,
played by Benedict Cumberbatch, who makes
a massive, universe-colliding mistake.
Using a spell to wipe everyone's minds and thus
make them forget that Peter Parker is Spider-Man,
the Sorcerer Supreme accidentally contorts
the multiverse in the worst way imaginable.
A host of recognizable Spidey foes from previous
continuities enter the Marvel Cinematic Universe
for the first time, ranging from Willem Dafoe's
Green Goblin from 2002's "Spider-Man" to Jamie
Foxx's Electro from "The Amazing Spider-Man
2." That's a tall order for the novice
Avenger and the protector of the Sanctum
Sanctorum, but luckily, they may have help.
Though the rumored Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield's Spider-Man incarnations have yet
to appear in any promos, some
viewers believe they've spotted
another fan-favorite hero in the "No Way
Home" teaser. Let's break down who it is,
and how they may fit into the
story, should they actually turn up.
"Are you a public defender?"
"Uh, no."
Despite being pinned as Mysterio's murderer,
it doesn't appear as though Peter Parker is
going on the run. Instead, as the
"No Way Home" trailer indicates,
Parker is cooperating with law enforcement
to get to the bottom of this case,
maintaining his innocence all the while.
Nevertheless, he can't win this fight alone,
meaning he will need someone to give
him a hand in court. Who better to do
so than Marvel's own Matt Murdock, better
known by his vigilante alias, Daredevil.
A whole army of other Twitter users have pointed
out that Charlie Cox's take on Daredevil,
made famous by the beloved Netflix series,
could be hiding in plain sight throughout
the "No Way Home" trailer. There are
multiple shots of Peter Parker sitting in
an interrogation room with what appears to
be a legal counsel of his own by his side,
slamming his hands down on the table. Curiously,
the person's face is strangely omitted every
time they're on screen. Of course, when
he's not cleaning up Hell's Kitchen,
Matt Murdock is a full-time lawyer, so his
involvement in Peter's case isn't too far-fetched.
It's also worth noting that Spider-Man and
Daredevil work together all the time in
the pages of Marvel Comics, meaning The Man
Without Fear could help out the web-slinger
with his villain problems at the movies as well.
Nevertheless, Cox's involvement in the project
is still unconfirmed, but fans do have reason
to hope that their theories could be correct.
The possibility of Charlie Cox appearing as
Matt Murdock in "Spider-Man: No Way Home"
is both exciting and not exactly a surprise.
There’s been quite a bit of speculation about
Cox being integrated into the larger MCU but
also a slew of rumors about him appearing in
"No Way Home." For instance, in December
2020, there were early rumors pointing
to Cox making an appearance in the next
"Spider-Man" movie. Then in January 2021,
ComicBook.com reported that Cox had allegedly
wrapped filming for his role in that project.
"Hearsay. Can't print any of it
without corroboration, can you?"
And the trail of breadcrumbs doesn't stop there.
There was a fresh round of speculation in July
2021 surrounding the fact that Cox was canceling
gigs at the same time that the "No Way Home"
reshoots were scheduled to take place. There have
also been rumors that Cox is gearing up to appear
in multiple upcoming MCU projects, including
"She-Hulk" and "Echo." If those rumors are true,
it's easy to think that the hotly anticipated "No
Way Home" could make for a perfect reintroduction.
And that's not all. According to Variety,
when the deals were inked to bring
live-action versions of Marvel characters
like Daredevil and Jessica Jones to Netflix,
there was allegedly a stipulation that those
characters could not appear in any other capacity
until two years after the cancelation
of the Netflix shows they originated on.
Matt Murdock, and his alias Daredevil,
passed that milestone at the end of 2020,
which would seem to mean that Marvel Studios
is totally free to welcome him back to the MCU.
We'll find out either way when "Spider-Man: No
Way Home" hits theaters on December 17, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
"Spider-Man: No Way Home" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.